Selam I'm Jam Fidel Jam CD and this is a
Mideast minute
[Music]
villagers thank you as always for tuning
in from Middle East today as we
broadcast to you live from Springfield
the hometown of a number of peacekeepers
in a recent interview Donald Trump
suggested that his son-in-law Jared
Kushner could play a pivotal role in
Middle Eastern peace talks leading many
to accuse mr. Trump of nepotism which
means it's time for us to put Jared
Kushner's political future in context
villager's chaired Kushner is not the
beneficiary of nepotism according to the
Oxford Dictionary nepotism is a practice
among those with power or influence of
favoring relatives and no one in a
position of power or influence is
favoring Kushner because he's a relative
especially not Trump he's a ruthless
businessman he puts America first not
family just listen to Esquires Vicky
Ward the trumps are hermetically sealed
unit it's family before anything or
anyone else yes exactly
he puts family before anything or anyone
else but only because they're qualified
prior to joining Trump's political
campaign Jared Kushner ran a
billion-dollar business and that's not
just the kind of thing your family hands
to you here's Andrea Mitchell on MSNBC
Jared took over his family's real estate
business when his father Charles Kushner
went to prison in 2005
yes exactly his family handed that to
him but only because Kushner was
qualified he attended Harvard University
one of the hardest schools to gain
admission to on the planet and it's not
as if anyone just handed his admission
to him here's NPR reporting on a book by
Daniel Goldin Charles Kushner gave to
charities hospitals and universities
including Harvard which admitted Jared
Kirchner after a 2.5 million dollar gift
yes exactly his family just handed that
to him but that doesn't mean that he's
unqualified to broker peace between
Israel and Palestine ok quite the
opposite he's immensely qualified
okay and as lawrence o'donnell reports
for MSNBC Trump himself has outlined why
he said quote Jared's a very smart guy
he's a quality person I think he can be
very helpful
exactly he's very smart so get ready for
peace I'm Jamshid on MCD and this has
been a Mideast minute
you